an unprecedented four-day conference
focusing on sexual abuse in the Roman
Catholic Church is underway this morning
and his opening remarks Pope Francis
told the meeting listen to the cries of
the young who want justice Vatican
officials say the summit will focus on
responsibility accountability and
transparency since 1950 more than 19,000
people have made allegations of abuse by
Catholic clergy in the United States
alone Seth Doane is in Rome at the
meeting that is seeking a renewal for
the church south good morning good
morning Pope Francis spoke today of the
scandals of pedophilia and the need for
the Catholic Church to transform that
evil into an opportunity to cleanse
itself surrounded by more than 100
bishops wearing the colored caps that
show their top ranks in the church Pope
Francis said what's needed is not simple
condemnation but concrete and effective
measures on the eve of the summit the
pontiff met with an abuse survivor from
Poland victims were not inside the
auditorium this morning though they're
videotaped testimony was played Cardinal
Lewis Tagle talked about the wounds
inflicted by bishops our lack of
response to the suffering of victims
even to the point of rejecting them and
covering up the scandal to protect
perpetrators and the institution has
injured our people the credibility of
Pope Francis himself has been called
into question notably last year during
his sex abuse crisis in Chile where
Francis initially sided with a predator
priests and against the abuse victims we
asked Hans older one of the organizers
of the summit about a pontiff seen as
slow to act he admitted that he made
only a mistake and and that was what at
least many of the survivors from Chile
really appreciated Archbishop Charles
should clue no once the Vatican's top
sex crimes investigator called for
clearer procedures for the reporting of
sexual abuse consulting outside experts
and cooperating with local law
enforcement transparency and speed in
the legal
with the victim playing a bigger role
and proper vetting for both seminarians
and bishops it is a sacred duty to
protect our people and to ensure justice
when they have been abused now what is
important to note is that many of these
guidelines were put in place by the u.s.
Catholic Church back in 2002 so now here
is the global body of the Catholic
Church discussing these guidelines again
17 years later Nora as many people hope
for change soon Seth Doane in Rome thank
you so much